jungle speed les loups garous de
thiercelieux ou encore time's up des
licences que vous avez peut-être
retrouvé au pied du sapin cette année
derrière ces jeux à succès l'entreprise
à ce mode est basé à guyancourt et pour
elle les jeux de société ont toujours la
cote à l'ol gérait 60% du chiffre
d'affaires se fait sur les 3 trois
derniers mois où effectivement on voit
les grosses tendances se dégagent et
quand numéro un du jeu qui reste
incontournable pour l'instant ne serait
ce que sur la le jeu pardon de base
c'est d'abord je dois continuer à bien
performer c'est numéro un des ventes
toutes catégories dans le jeu on parle
de plus de deux cent mille copies
vendues par donc rejoint rien que cette
année en france 20 millions de boîtes de
jeux ont été vendus depuis 2011 d'après
ndp group spécialiste des études de
marché
en l'espace de 20 ans à ce mode et s'est
imposé comme l'un des leaders européens
de la distribution de jeux de société
dans ses écuries on retrouve également
les jeux de cartes à collectionner et
cette année encore pokémon a raflé la
mise parce qu'on est aussi le
distributeur donc le pokémon en france
et avec le phénomène pokémon go qui nous
a permis effectivement de donner encore
un coup de lumière sur cette très belle
licence qui était déjà très forte ce
qu'on attend c'est parfois l'oublier
mais pokemon reste toujours depuis 20
ans une licence assez forte dans le jeu
de cartes à collectionner 95% du jeu de
cartes
en france c'est monopolisé par un
pokémon chaque année l'enseigne
distribué dit 200 nouveautés
de quoi déjà donné des idées au père
noël pour 2017